サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日のお釈迦様の真理の教えをね
法話のお布施は柳潤一さんのお布施で行っています
仏教はこのお布施することはとても素晴らしい善行だと説かれています
一切の善の諸法は施しなんですね
いわゆる自分で私のものやと思っているものを自分から離す
離してみる それもたくさん人々の幸福のために話すことができれば
有意義的な話し方になります
有意義的な捨て方になります
自分持っているものは宝物であってもね
ポイッとゴミ箱に捨てることもできます
しかし そこでは終わりですね
リサイクルにならないんですね
だからこのお布施っていうのは
この自分のものやと思っているものは
他の生命のためにリサイクルに回すことなんですね
だからこのその中でも
臓器移植とかね そういうこともあれば
自分の国でもよく一般的で
誰かが病気になっちゃうと
誰かがそういう腎臓とかね
提供しちゃうんですね
で なんかこの間のアヌシシュオカの方でスリランカのお寺があります
そちら行ったら 自分たちもウェーサーカ祭りとかの時は献血運動をやっているんだと
そこに来たその関係の方々は
自分たちがこの仕事を始めてから
こんなたくさんの人が出てきてね
こんな大量に手に負えないぐらい人々は献血するということは初めての経験であると
ということは スリランカ仏教徒たちのウェーサーカ祭りでしたから
いろんなところに住んでいるスリランカ人たちがそこで集まって
みんなもう献血する そういう風にこのいろんなお布施の仕方があります
そこで 自分のものというものが他人のためにリサイクルすることなんですね
その中でも 仏教では命を差し上げることよりも
ブッダの教えをお布施することが生命の役に立つんだと
ですから今日はこの柳潤一さんがこのお布施の間違ったね
法施のね 真理を皆様にお布施をする善行を行いましたので
仏法僧から柳さんとご家族の皆様方に
また会社の仕事をするところのね
自分の関係ある方々に
友人たちに 皆様に仏法僧のご加護がありますように
幸福で幸せで 安穏で安らぎを感じながら日々生活できますようにと
それから心の煩悩が今日の行為
お布施の行為と同じく
心の煩悩がなくなって
完全たる解脱である安穏である涅槃に達することが健やかに早くもできますようにと
まず誓願いたします 皆様も三回サードゥ
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい 今日の話になります
なんか変な話ですね 本物の恐怖とはということが本当のタイトルです
上のタイトルはまあ冗談ですね
そこでこのなんかこの皆様にこの講演のテーマを発表した時のコピーペーストがありまして
なんか私はこれ面白いなと思ったんですね
普段私はコピーペースト使わないし
そこから話は始まりませんけどね
だからコピーをまた これ私が読むよりはテツロさんに読み上げた方が理解しやすいでしょう
はい では読み上げます
はい お化けが怖い 先祖の霊が怖い
地縛霊が怖い 祟りが怖い
悪魔が怖い お隣の怪しいおじさんが怖い
通り魔が怖い サイコパスが怖い
女が怖い 男が怖い 同性愛者が怖い
他民族が怖い 津波が怖い
火山の噴火が怖い その他自然災害が怖い
伝染病が怖い 交通事故が怖い
犯罪に巻き込まれるのが怖い
戦争が怖い カルト勧誘が怖い
そして都市伝説が怖い
政府 政府が怖い 都市伝説ですね
政府が怖い 宇宙人の戦略が怖い
はい そこで一旦ちょっと説明して
次にまたコピー続きます
だからわしのお化けが怖い
戦争の霊が怖いとかね
地縛霊怖いって言ったら
勝手に死なさいよとね
解決策はないんですね
勝手に怯えなさいよと
祟りが怖い とにかく自分の妄想で恐怖感を感じると気が弱いんですね
で 悪魔が怖いと言っても
会ったことある？悪魔にね
隣の怪しいおじさんが怖いんだったら
まあまあ見てないふりをすればいいでしょうしね
まあ通り魔が怖いって言ったら
怪しいところに行かなきゃいいでしょうに
まあサイコパス このサイコパスという
もしかしたら英語の単語やと思いますけどね
まあそれはちょっとね
よくわかりませんね 人がサイコパスかないかっていうことはね
だから 顔に顔色見てね
なんか顔が死体のようだったら
ちょっと気をつけた方がいいんですね
顔がニコニコと笑っているならばね
まあそれって問題ないやと思いますね
女が怖いんだったら逃げてくださいと思いますね
で そこでこの同性愛者が怖いとか
他民族が怖いとかね というところは
この人間の差別ですね
あんた勝手に生命差別して勝手に怖がりなさいよと
自業自得でしょ この中でこの私だったらリストはある
論理的に並べますけど
これそのままコピー写しちゃったんですね
だからここでいろいろ女が男が怖いっていうのは
どんな精神状態かよくわからない
いろいろありますからね
まあ女が怖いっていうことは私もよくわかりますけどね
で 同じく女性は男が怖いと思う
それもよくわかりますよね
女性の立場から見たら
もう本当に怖いでしょうね
そこでこの他民族が怖いとかね
あれやこれやとかね 外人が怖いとかね
私もよく思い存分言われた
言われて生きて生きてきたんだからね
みんなに怖いとかね 勝手にしろね
俺には関係ないんだという感じでいたんですけどね
で 津波が怖い 火山噴火怖いっていうのはね
まあどうしようもない自然災害が怖いとね
まあそれはあることで
人間にはどうすることもできない
伝染病が怖いと思ってもね
今ほとんどないんですね
で 交通事故が怖いと言ったらね
まあ安全運転しなさいよでしょ
ふざけないで 犯罪に巻き込まれるのが怖いと
巻き込まれませんよ 犯罪に自分がだらしないんだったらね
巻き込まれる可能性あります
じゃなくて 別に 戦争が怖いのは政府に言ってください
戦争したがるのは各国の政府でしょ
それでも国民がやりたくないと言ったらどうする？軍隊があってもいいんだよ
軍隊は 例えば日本の軍隊
自衛隊と言うんですね
日本の安全を守っている軍隊の人々をね
出るなよと国民が言ったら
国民の司令が憲法より上なんです
法的力は だからそれもそれなりに解決できますね
カルト勧誘が怖いというのはね
あんた情けないでしょうね
自分で理性を持って議論すればね
勧誘されたしたからって
なんで勧誘されるんですかね
もう関係ない いりませんって言っちゃえばね
で まあ都市伝説はよくわからない
私は 政府が怖い これは怖いですよ
政府は これはしょうがないんです
宇宙人の戦略が怖いと
映画見ないでください
ちょっと何かあの よくわからないバグが入っちゃって
このこれ二回動くんです
これ取り消そうと思ったんだけど
はい 次読んでみますか
地獄が怖い 饅頭が怖い
饅頭ってこれどんな意味？ あの
こっちですね  はい 次  妄想を回転するならば
怖いリストをどこまででも伸ばせます
はい そこまでですね この最後の行は
だから私の話です で あの
このイントロダクションセクションでもわかるのは
なんか怖い怖いって なんかいい加減でしょうね
結局は あんまり分析する必要でもない
くだらん で 戦争の兵のたたりが怖いとかね
そんなのあるわけないでしょうに
自分のおじいさんが自分の首を絞めたく
あの霊界で待ってるんだよとか
ありえない話でしょ いくらなんでも
で この家族同士の争いっていうのはいろいろありますけど
この生きている場合はちょっといじめたり
いろいろあるかもしれませんだけど
親戚だから まあどこかで繋がってはいるんですよ
そこで結論で言えるのは
自分の妄想を回転すれば
怖いもののリストは無限大に伸ばすことはできます
時々精神的な病気で すごい潔癖症で
ちょっと考えて 潔癖症だからそこら中細菌だらけでしょ
で こう体皮膚ものすごい細菌だらけなんです
口の中でも 腸の中でも
細菌 細菌 細胞の中を見ても細菌が入っているんだから
で これで潔癖症ってやるならば徹底してやってほしいんです
細胞も怖い 気持ち悪いんだと
細胞の中にも他の生命体が入っているんだよと
だからまあ 自分が妄想する
どこまで妄想するのかと
で 皮膚の中にたくさん細胞
細菌がいる 別に知らん
それだけでお話終わりでしょうに
だからこれって妄想なんですね
例えば男が怖い 女が怖いとか
例えば歩いてる人が怖いとかね
いうのは 自分勝手にイメージ作って
顔を形何かで頭で妄想しちゃって怖いと言うんですね
あの人最低この野郎でも言ったならば
あ 怖いと思ってもいいんだけど
そうじゃなく 気持ちで怖いと言うんですね
そういうことで この恐怖感というのは精神的な病気なんです
だから皆様に勝手に自分の精神病の重度さ
どれぐらいと測れます
あなたにどれぐらい怖いものあるのかと
それによってもうあれもこれもこれもこれも怖い怖いと思っちゃうとね
かなり病気なんですね
空き家が怖いとか 例えば人が自殺したアパートには住みたくない
もう怖いとかね 私だったらもう喜んでそちらでもあれ
半額にしてくださいと
もうものすごくお化けが出ますよと
大家さんに言ってね 夜はもう自分の首も絞められますよと言っても
家賃半額にしてもらった方が楽じゃないかなと思います
どういったことはね まさ死んだ人が幽霊になってきたら楽しいでしょうに
誰かがいるんだから だから出かける場合はね
ちゃんと家を留守番してねとかね
言って帰れるし 出かけるし
だからこの心明るい人には
そういうふうに楽しく物事を受け取れることができますね
ということで 最初のポイントを覚えてください
あれこれ怖い怖いということは
自分の妄想の結果であって
妄想することは精神病で
精神病気がかなり結果出している
だから感染していることはいくらでもありますね
例えば 私の体にいろいろな病気の原因がありますけど
病気は別発生していないんですね
キャリアとしている 例えば
誰だってがんになれるでしょうに
でもみんながんになれるわけじゃないでしょうに
がんになる可能性だけを持っている
そこまでは大丈夫です
発病することがもう結果出たということなんですね
それから大変なんです
それから この喜怒哀楽の感情を妄想的にかき回して再現することが娯楽だというんですね
皆さんは娯楽とか好きでしょうね
あれっていうのは あの病気になる感情をかき回すんです
人工的に本を読むとかね
映画を見るとかね 音楽を聴くとかね
舞台を観賞するとか そういうことで人工的にあの精神病気の感情をかき回す
かき回して まあ喜怒哀楽を自分が感じちゃうんです
何もないのに 何もない
なんか考えてください
例えば映画を見る場合は
プロジェクターからスクリーンに光が映しているだけでしょうに
それで楽しくなるわ なんてあの女優さんがなんて可愛いんですかねとかね
頭イカれるまで ああ かっこいいとかね
それは男性でも女性でもありますね
何もないところで自分が病気になってしまっただけ
だから仏教は大体娯楽に対して
に対してはあんまり賛成的じゃない
病気の連中がやっていることだから
ごちゃごちは悪口言いませんよ
病気で苦しんでいる人が泣いた
喚いた 怒鳴ったと言っても気にしないでしょ
病気だからしょうがない
だから世間は娯楽中毒にいることには
あんまり仏教はあまり何も言いません
まあ勝手にやりなさい
でも仏教はそれはあまり賛成しないんで
なぜならばそれは意図的に
例えば本物の美人を見て頭がおかしくなったならば
人間ここに目の前にいるんだからね
いくらか仕方がないねと言えますけど
このスクリーンで映った光に頭がイカれちゃうと
どうしますかね 従って
恐怖 不安 怯え 軽薄感のテーマも芸術作品にしているんです
だから芸術作品というのは
いつでも濃い物語だけではなくて
まあいろんな悪魔が来るわ
もう幽霊が来るわね エイリアンが来るわ
まあそれそういうふうに幻覚作って
人々の病気をかき回してみようではないかなと
だから映画を見て その瞬間だけで興奮しちゃって
ケロッと忘れる人々もいる
それ忘れない 引きずっちゃう人々もいる
だからエイリアンという映画を見たら
頭にこびりついちゃうとどうしますかと
だから あんなもんで金儲けるのは正しい合法的な収入じゃないんです
だから人を病気にしてあげて金取ってるんだから
これは強盗なんですね
人にお弁当作ってあげて
まあ五百円で売ってね
自分が百円ぐらい儲かったら
それはぴったり正しい合法的な収入なんです
自分が頑張ったんです
で 弁当買った人がそれで食べて幸せになっているんです
だから自分がもらったお金は
本当に力のある 自分に使える
簡単に溶けてしまわない金になるんです
だから我々こっちを誤解しているのは
このお金っていうのは数字で数字
桁が大きい大きい方がいいやと思ってるでしょ
そうじゃないんです 桁の大きい収入があっても
大したことはね 全部無駄になる人もいるし
桁が少なくても金がすごく硬くてなかなか消えないというね
収入もありますね ですから
それは合法的に正しく
ダンマに従って道徳を犯さないで得た収入の場合なんです
お釈迦様が推薦っているのは
最低はどうしても仕事をしなくちゃいけない
その場合は汗を流して
よく努力して頑張って収入を得てくださいという話なんですね
そういうわけで この芸術世界でも人々の恐怖感をかき回す芸術はあります
ですから 金を払って怖さを感じる人々も宿
少なくないのです これ間違ってますね
で 少なくないんですね
面白いでしょう 金払って病気になっていただくという
あの この間私もあのお化け屋敷に行ったんです
8月だからね まあ自分が面白くないんだけど
まあ子供二人がね 連れて行ったんだからね
で 子供といろいろ遊んだりして
私 最初からね お化け屋敷に行く行くと言うんだけど
まあいやいやと言うんですね
で 他全部遊んで終わってから
お化け屋敷の夜のバージョンになっちゃったんです
そうすると 新たに入場料お金を払わなくちゃ
これすごい金額なんです
すごく高くなったんだけど
私が見たいんだからと言って
私は無理やりでお化け屋敷に
入ってみたんですね やはり子供がすごく最初から何もない玄関のところでも怖くなっちゃって
いろいろ教えてくれる
幽霊が出てくるんだからね
怨霊がね そうするとこの極めのロープをね
首にかけてあげてください
そうすると幽霊が救われますよとかね
いろいろありますね 私はじゃああなたと
いえいえ 先生持ってください
じゃあそこに座って で
まあ中暗いんだから 私の目が悪いしね
見えないんですね まあ薄暗い
それは見えるんだけど
一旦入ったら閉じ込められた状態で
どこから出ればいいかわからなくなっちゃう
それで子供二人もどう私の体にもう繋いでいてね
私はもうこれどこから出かけるの？もうできないでしょって
あの二人のすごく目が見えるんです
こちらで え？うちら何もないでしょ？カーテンだけで
こちらで だからそういうことで私は案内する羽目になっちゃって
外に出たら二人は全然怖くなくなっちゃって
何の意味もお金無駄とか
で そこでちっちゃな子はまあ先生全然怖がらなかったんだからね
もう全然面白くなかったと
私は怖くなるはずがないし
ね だからその場合もね
お化け屋敷に入って怖がりたければ妄想が必要なんですね
そしたら一旦一回ちょっとこれ変だなと思うとこがあって
この小さな部屋があって
布団 2つ敷いてあるんですね
で 何もない だからこれは布団いて小さな部屋だからね
出口は別なところでしょうと言ったら
子供いい 向こう出口があるんです
向こうの出口に行けないで
この布団いてるんだから
布団を踏んではいけませんよと
だからそれは普通の常識で
布団の上で子供ならごちゃごちゃ行くかもしれませんだけど
大の男はね 大人はね 布団の上で踏んでいくことはしないでしょうね
で 仕方がなく 私はもうしょうがないと言って布団の上に踏んであと言ったら
布団の中何かあるんですね
ジリジリと 無難なことなく出て行ったんですけどね
はい それからまあ仏教的にあの
この問題を分析してみましょう
で だからこの大体この月例講演というのは
ブッダの教えを皆様 日本の方々にね
紹介する目的でやっているんであって
別に信仰しなさいとか
勧誘する目的は何もないんです
イントロダクションなんで
こういうものであると
ですから この宗教的な迷信的な
こういう何もなく 精密に論理的に物事を見て解説してあげるというのは
お釈迦様のやり方なんですね
ですから この恐怖感というのも分析はあります
最初に言ったのは自作の安全というテーマなんですね
非 人は でも生命は人だけじゃない
この恐怖感があるのは我々人間だけじゃないよ
他の生命も全ての生命はすごい恐怖感に怯えるんです
ある経典に 神々すらかなり怯えていますよと
書いてあるし 人は自分特有の安全イメージを作ります
一人一人に 自分には自分の安全というイメージがあるんです
赤ちゃんの時から老人になるまで
このイメージを改良したり変化させたりします
この安全イメージがずっと同じものじゃないんです
だから 赤ちゃんの安全のイメージと小一年生の安全イメージが違うんです
そこで中学生の安全イメージがまた違うんですね
そういう風に 例えばちっちゃな子供たちは
親がそばにいることがもう決定的な条件になる
大きくなってくると まあ親がいなくても
別なところででも 友達と一緒にいる時でも
安全というイメージを作ったりしますから
それは変わります 年寄りになってくると
それまた変わっちゃうんですね
だから皆様に聞いても
あなたの安全イメージはどういうこと？と言って
よくわからないと思いますね
これ引き出す方法がありますよ
あなたの人生はどうなった方があなたは安全だと思う？という質問
自分に聞いてみて 今皆様に聞いちゃうとね
まあ日が暮れますからね
だから自分に聞いてみる
どうなった方が私にとって安全でしょうかと
この作業には必ず思考する必要ありません
だから いきなり聞いたらわからなくなる
わからなくなっちゃうのはそういうわけなんです
なんとなく安全イメージが出来上がっちゃうんです
を考えて 論理的にそうできるものじゃないんです
ん？しかし 安全イメージは様々な条件で壊れます
恐怖を感じる その時 安全が壊れるかもしれないと思っただけでも恐怖が起きます
そこで精神状態を理解できるでしょうかね
私には安全というイメージがある
これはあんまりよくわからない
よく自分に 問いてみなきゃわからない
自分の心に聞いてみなきゃ
だから 今皆様に質問を出したんだから問題ないんだけど
自分に聞いてみてくださいと
私にとって安全とは何と
そうすると 自分が今無意識的に作ったイメージが出て現れて出てくるんです
完全には出てこない なんとなく出てきます
こんな感じかなとかね
そこで一般的な人はそのイメージに気づいてない
安全イメージに 気づいてないんだけど
社会では いろんな出来事が起こります
起きた出来事で安全イメージが壊れちゃうんですね
だから本人はいきなり恐怖になっちゃうわけ
なんでそれで怖いのかと聞いてもわからない
わからない理由は 安全イメージに気づいてない
気づいていたならば それほど精神的に怖くなって変なことにならないと思います
そこでこの 安全が壊れるかもしれないと思っただけでもね
怖い 例えば会社で仕事をしていて
なかなか自分の仕事はうまく進まない
で どんどん能力も低下する
自分も年取っている 会社の環境も悪くなってくると
もしかするとクビになったらと思ったら
それ怖くなっちゃうんです
病気になっちゃうんです
まだクビになってないんです
はい 次の恐怖感の理由は
先がわからないということなんです
覚えておいてください
1安全イメージ  2番目は先がわからない
安全感は現在と将来に関係ある概念です
この人の安全 安全ということは
この現在と将来に関わるものなんです
そこで現在って具体的だから
今は皆様怖がっている
ないね 今は安全ですね
でもこれ 屋根が落ちたらどうする？天井が
大学の建物だから頑丈ですね
大丈夫ですね 冗談じゃないんだけどね
大丈夫じゃないんです
何も あと三分で全て壊れるかなという
はい それ そんなこと思っちゃってきていられないでしょ
だから我々は現在においては
今日は十日 十日で東京の方に送ると予定されている大地震が起きないでしょうと
起きても これ大学の建物だから
これ相当頑丈にできてますね
だから安全でしょうと
建物あれから壊れたってもとか
まあなんとか現在に対してはそれほど怖がらないんですけど
次は将来なんですね みんなこの将来の安全考えているんですね
しかし 誰にも先のことわからない
これよく覚えてください
先のことわかる人はいません
知りたい人は因縁関係を知らなくてはいけないが
因縁関係も決定的に定めたものではありません
先が読めたければ お釈迦様と同じく因果法則を理解しなくちゃいけない
だからお釈迦様は因果法則を徹底的に究極的に調べて知ったんだけど
お釈迦様も予言していないんです
何一つ なぜならば いつ条件変わるかわからないんです
そういうことですよ だから自分の体に体力があるんだ
体が健康だとかね まあ自慢でにいろいろ
健康診断を受けたところで
すべて合格で全然問題ありませんと思っていても
どこかでちょっと滑ったりとかね
何か起きちゃったら あれが全部なくなっちゃうんですよ
例えば ある人がちょっと藪で歩いていくと蛇に噛まれると
それで予言してあげる
あんた あと 3時間経ったところで蛇に噛まれますよと
で その人 ああそうですかね
予言されたんだから仕方がないと思っても
3時間そこら辺蛇に噛まれる環境
避けたらどうですかね
そうすると蛇に噛まれなくなっちゃうんです
だから先を言えないんです
だから予言者たちでできてきている宗教っていうのは簡単に嘘の塊なんです
イスラム教っていうのはもう預言者の話で
最後の預言者はモハメッドさんであると
最後の預言者ってどうやって決めたんですかね？もっとアホな人はそれからも現れるでしょ
この地球に生きている人々は
で そう信じていてね で
キリスト教の場合でもね
イエスが来るというところまで預言者をダラダラダラダラ並べているんですね
だから予言不可能ですよ
で 神様の話があるんで
神様に予言できないんですね
面白い 聖書がつかれます
最後の審判をしますとかね
その時悪魔を倒しますとかね
いつでしょうか？と聞いたら
神様すらわからない いるならばいないから問題ないんだけどね
ですから推測できても
将来を知ることは不可能です
では 将来知ること不可能であるならば
どうやって将来の安全を作れますかね
先がわからないという事実の前で
安全イメージが揺らぎます
怖くなります だから怖いという気持ちが誰にでもあります
なぜ 誰にでも先が読めないんです
はい 次のポイントは想定外
先がわからないのに認めたくはないんですね
占い師の方に行くでしょ？いくらなんでも
手相占いやら髪型占いやら
いろいろ歯型占い 何お茶占いね
コーヒー占いもあるんだからね
本当にアホなんですよ
先が読めないのに認めたくない
知りたいんですね 個人の主観的な想定は普遍的な法則に関係がありません
そこで私たちはいろんなことを想定する
飛行機に乗る 無事着陸できるということを想定しているんです
途中で墜落するかもしれませんということはないんでしょ？だからみんなすごい気持ちよく飛行機に乗りますけど
その飛行機に乗れるということは
飛行機は墜落しないという想定があるから
でもその想定ってどういうこと？自然法則に関係ないでしょ
わからないでしょ もし飛行機が飛んでいると
エアポケットというね
空気圧がないところがあって
そしたらドッカンと結構落ちちゃうんですね
で 落ちた瞬間で飛行機の操縦がうまくいかなかったらどうしますかね
だからもうすごい高度は上がるんだからいいんだけど
高度が上がっている途中で
どこかから飛んで鳥でも入り込んだらどうします？だからほんのちょっとのことで状況が変わってしまうんですね
だからそういうのは法則です
我々は法則と関係なく想定するんです
そういうのは仏教用語でダンマニヤマと言うんで
ダンマっていうのは世の中の法則で
法則には法則の法則ですから
それはそれなりに起きている
それはあまり変わりません
法則だけは一定するんです
ある程度 例えば地球の自転というのはある程度で一定しているんです
自転も公転も しかし 必ずしもその通りということは言いづらいんです
過去をずっと調べてみても
同じスピードで自転してだろうということはまあ言えますよ
でもこれからも 100万年後でもね
1億年後でも 地球はこのようにあるということはどう言える？だからそれはいろいろ条件変わっちゃうとどうなるかわからない
しかし 法則はそのまま
法則は変わらない ですから
人は勝手にいろんなことを想定するんだけど
それはあんまりにも意味がないことなんですね
目の前で現象が変化して流れる時
主観的な想定が壊れます
だから我々は毎日経験しますね
想定とは違いましたとかね
想定していなかったとかいうこと
毎日起こるんですよ その時は怖くなります
イライラします  電車に乗ろうかなと思ったらね
新幹線に乗ると東京駅に入って
まあちゃんと時間に行って
知らないどこかで 静岡の辺り
あるいはもうちょっと前のところで
突然台風が来てなんとか起きちゃって
竜巻が来て 線路に何か入ったと
落ちたと 動かないでしょ
運転見合わせになりますね
それで想定していたんです
この時間でどこかに行くと
名古屋に行くと そこでイライラする
怖くはならないかもしれませんけど
その場合は で かなり興奮する
あるいは新幹線途中でそのまま止まったらどうしますかね
何か線路に何かあって
そうすると歩いては行けませんね
隣の駅までは だからまあ
心はこの状態を処理しない
処理できないので恐怖に襲われます
想定したものと違ったものが起きちゃうと
心は勝手に想定して安心感でいたんだからね
で 変わったら どうしますかと
自分の心にわからないんです
はい これ一つの原理 次のポイントは存在欲
生きる時は眼耳鼻 生きる時は眼耳鼻舌身で色声香味触法という情報を認識します
生きるというのはそういうことです
大胆なことじゃないんです
ただ 眼耳鼻舌身があって
そちらに色声香味触法が触れる
触れたら認識する 感覚という刺激が起こる
そこで感じるという刺激が起こるんです
目で感じる 耳で感じる
この感じることにみんな命命と言っているんです
分かってない 命ってないんです
感じるだけなんです だから感じることにして
科学的に生きるとは感じることやと言ったら
感じることは数点化するんです
自分好きなように操縦できません
例えば この花を見て花だとそういう感覚が生まれる可能性もあります
はい これはこの 何か色だと感じてみて
できる？できないね じゃあ白熊やと
白いところもあるでしょ
北極熊やと感じてみて
できないでしょう で 自分好きなように感じることはできないんです
感覚は勝手に起こる 目に入るものにとって
耳に入る音によって勝手に起こる
だから音楽が流れたからといって
みんな同じ感覚生まれるわけじゃないんです
ものすごく勝手なんです
それが感じることが命というんですね
だから世界は非科学者だからね
科学といえば正真正銘の科学はブッダの教えだけです
これは断言的に言えるんです
皆様が信仰している科学は
ただ物質を追じているだけで
すべて曖昧で不確定の世界なんです
だから生きることっていうのは
ブッダが説かれた科学的に見ると感じることです 6
種類感じることがあるんです
これは勝手に起きて勝手に消える
勝手に起きて勝手に消える
例えば 皆様方 今座った時からのこの花を見ていてならば
同じ感覚じゃないんですよ
時間経つたびに どんどん変わっていく
15分ぐらいになってきたらあったっけ？って忘れるぐらい
花があったの？とか それぐらいになっちゃうんです
そこで我々はアホだから
あの感覚に愛着を抱くんです
花に愛着は抱けないんです
そこから体で起きた感覚に愛着を抱くんです
それまた勘違いしてて
あの花が欲しいと言っちゃうんです
あの歌が欲しいと言っちゃうんです
あれは間違いです あんたは歌が欲しくはないんです
だったらCDをね ポケットに入れて大事に持てばいいでしょう
じゃなくて 感覚に愛着を持ったんです
だから ものすごい愛着した感覚
耳の感覚があって CD
買って それでどんどん何回も繰り返し繰り返し聞いていると
またあの愛着は変わっていくんです
だからもう 自分という概念にはもう入る余地はないんです
刺激を受け続けるために生き続けなくてはいけないと決断するんです
そこで私たちは目でいい感覚を感じたい
耳でいい感覚を感じたい
鼻でいい感覚を感じたい
舌でいい感覚を感じたい
体でいい感覚を感じたい
思考でいい気持ちを感じたいということで
これは翻訳するんです
生き続けたいと 生き続けなくては
これは成り立たないんだと
それに存在欲というんです
すべて 間違っているプログラムなんです
生きているということは理解していない
生きているということは
六つの感覚の流れがごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ生まれて消えて生まれて消えていくこと
どうにもならない もう激しく流れる川をイメージしてください
激しく勢いで流れている
どうにもならんでしょ
川の激しい流れを見ているだけ見ていると
それなりに自分の気持ちも変わって変わっていく
どうにもならん 例えば
川を観察している人に
自分という意思が 使用することできますかね
はい こんな感じの波が見たいな
こんな感じの渦巻き見たいなとかね
こんな感じのこと見たいなとかね
できないでしょ それはご飯食べる時も同じことで
こういう味を味わいたいと思ってご飯食べても
その味は味わえませんよ
ご飯が噛む時 自分の舌で
感じさせるものを味わえなくてはいけないんです
それはいつでも一定してないんです
変わるんです しかし 私たちはこの不可能な愛着を作ったんです
花が欲しいと 私は花が好きやと
もうアホなんです あんた花が好きじゃなくて
あんたあるところで どこかで花を見た時は
あなたの目でいい感覚が生まれただけやと
だから必ずしもこの花はいつでもその感覚を作ってくれる保証はありませんよと
わかったら愛着は生まれませんよ
我々は愛着を作っちゃって
それ愛着を続けるためには生きていなくちゃいけないとか
また勘違いして その勘違いに存在欲というんですね
生きていきたいという欲
しかし 一切の現象は無常です
固定した存在欲は妄想です
皆様は誰でも持っている存在欲
生きていきたいと あれは妄想です
現実じゃないんです 存在欲がある限り
恐怖感は消えません だって存在欲があるということは
自分が想定した感覚セット
それを繰り返しリピートしてほしいでしょ
ありえないんです だから怖くなります
はい これすごい大きなポイントですよ
次に行きましょうか 死を認識できないというポイント
知識にも感情にも自分の死
死という 概念はありません
皆様相当の知識の人でしょ？エリートの方々でしょ？私以外は
アホ私だけなんです 何も勉強しない
皆様の知識をちょっと調べてください
死という概念があるのかと
うなぎは美味しいとかね
あるかもしれませんよ
しかし 自分の死 それは知識にはないんです
感情にもないんです 存在すらしないんです
例は出しにくいんだけど
例えば我々は三次元世界にいるんですね
誰かが数学だけで言ってますけど
じゃあ六次元世界もあるんだと
では六次元世界の花はどんなものかと
わからない 理解できない
じゃあ次元でいるんだから
二次元一元は知ってますね
頭で でも経験することは不可能です
二次元は一応できますけどもね
一元はまたもできない
そういうことで この死ということ
知識にも感情にも存在しないんです
ある程度で変化はわかります
自分の体が変化していることはわかります
過去のデータと比較すると
変わりましたとわかります
消えた現象の代わりに新たな現象が現れますから
新たに起きた現象に愛着
愛着を移します だから
二十歳の女性が三十五歳になると
自分が変わったとわかります
何するのかというと 二十歳の肉体にあった愛着を三十五歳の肉体に移してあげるんです
だから人間もよく変でしょ？年にふさわしくない生き方をしているでしょ？年は三十五歳
ごまかす 女に年聞くなよと
へっちゃらで言うんです
ということは 女が認め
我々は幻覚 妄想の中で生きているんだよと
だから誰かがあなたは二十二歳にしか見えませんよと言ったら
もう抜群ですね 男たちはそれをわかってないで言っちゃえと
六十歳であっても あなたすごい超若いねとかね
結構受けますよ だから男も男で自分が年取ってジジイになってるのに
若い肉体にあった愛着を移しちゃうんです
衰えた肉体に これで困るんですね
七十歳になった男性が気持ち的には四十歳でいるんですね
無理でしょ だから死をわからないのはそういうわけなんです
もう瞬間瞬間死んでいるんです
死んで新たな現象が生まれるんです
新たな現象にあの愛着を移すさんです
愛着を移さなかったら
死を感じることはできます
これは一般人にできない
だからこれは超越した認識能力が必要なんです
超逸と言ったっても もうなんかわけのわからない形而上学的なものじゃないんです
ちょっと知恵をレベルを上げるだけなんです
年取っていく時間単位で
秒単位で変わる体を観察してください
しかし 愛着を移さないでください
それだけ その時 あ 死んでいるんだとわかるんです
すべては一期一会だと理解しないので
常に自分がいるという錯覚が変わりません
だからみんな私がいるんだとかね
西洋哲学は何ですかね
すべて私がいるんだぞという哲学でしょ
仏教哲学はお前いないんだ
いないんだぞという哲学でしょ
初めからもいなかったし
今もいないし これからもいないんだよと
あんた幻覚やと これは
この幻覚は起こるからくりはこういうからくりだと
今そのからくり一部説明しているんです
命を危うく すべてのものは恐怖の対象になる
その結果 命を危うくというものあると思っちゃうんです
そんなものないんです
命っていうのは瞬間瞬間死ぬものなんです
体も心も え？ 命を危うくする
うん 危うくする あと入れてください
もう書くのめんどくさい
命を危うくする すべてのものは恐怖の対象になります
しかし 外と内の世界は命を危うく現象のみでできています
これ正しいかどうかわかりません
危うくするですか  危うくする
うん うん 外の世界 この肉体以外
外の世界 この肉体の外の世界
こちらぶつかるたびにこちら壊れていくんです
そういう風になっているんです
支えてくれません 壊すんです
では 夏の太陽に体を当ててみて
どうなる？壊れるでしょ
寒さに当ててみて どうなる？壊れるでしょ
そこで  夏の太陽だったら大変だけど
まあなんか優しい太陽の光だったら大丈夫
そんなことはありえないんです
太陽は太陽です 光が強烈か弱いだそれでのことです
暴風に当たったら怖いんだけど
そよ風に当たっても大丈夫
そんなことないんで 風は風です
だからこんな元気でいる場合じゃないんですよ
目にものを触れるたびに体が壊れる
耳に音が触れるたびに体が壊れる
空気が触れるたびに体が壊れていく
外から内からどうですかね
壊れることで出来上がっているんです
生きるということは壊れることなんです
細胞は壊れていくんです
それが生きることなんです
息を吸ったら酸素が入るでしょうに
酸素が入ったら燃えるでしょ
細胞の中に 壊れない？壊れるんです
我々心配するのは この酸素が十分体に入らない場合は
ラディカルという酸素が生まれるんですね
だから壊れた酸素 酸素ってとっても危ないものなんです
窒素と違うんです 酸素の仕事は物を壊すことなんです
でも私たちは酸素のおかげで生きているでしょ
酸素はありがたいと ありがたくないんです
酸素は壊すんです そこでラディカルになっちゃうと
あれ 何酸素と言うんですか？活性酸素
活性酸素 その場で破壊するんですよ
細胞は過ぎたところ 細胞を破壊するんです
だからいろんな果物を食べたり
活性酸素をなくそうではなくて無理です
水素水もありますね それ水素ラディカル一つを余分に入れた水
私は飲んでますけど 私は飲んでいるのは健康のためじゃなくて
なんか気持ちいいんです
飲んでみるとそれだけ
だからみんなやっていることも何かやらなきゃね
世間のあれにも尻尾をなくしちゃったことも
だって一緒に生活できないでしょ
みんなアホだったら自分はアホを演じないと
で そんなのは本当は意味がないんです
じゃあ意味がないからといってどうする？呼吸しないようにする
太陽の光に体を当てないようにする
空気に体触れないようにする
ご飯食べないようにする
無理でしょ だから理解してください
外と内っていうのは壊れる現象で出来上がっているんです
命っていうのはそういうものです
永遠命じゃなくて 死ぬことが命なんです
壊れることが命なんです
破壊することが命なんです
それで頭イカれてるんだから生きていきたい
私は死にたくはない 死ってもう理解もできないんだとか
あ ちょっと言い忘れたことがあります
死は理解できないと言ったら
皆様え？嘘でしょ？と思っちゃうでしょ
それはあなたの死じゃないんです
これ おじいさん おばあさんの死でしょ
おじいさんが死んじゃったとかね
お母さんが死んじゃったとか
飼っていたペットのワンちゃんが死んじゃったとかね
それは知ってますよ だって毎日死体食べてるでしょ
だからこのそうやって別な細胞組織が機能低下し停止していることは知ってますけど
この細胞組織の機能停止は認識できないんです
ですから 人が感じる恐怖は計り知れないんです
生きていきたいんだからね
成り立たないんです それは
ずっと壊れて壊れていくんです
壊れることが命なんです
中から壊れる 外からデータぶつけて壊れていく
だからもっと面白い ちょっと俗っぽい言葉にすれば
あなたはただで座っていても年を取る
あなたは座っている時
音楽を聴いているならば
さらに年を取る あなたは音楽をやめて本を読んでいるならば
さらにスピーディーに年を取る
あなた座っていないで
ちょっと運動してしたならば
もっとスピーディーに年を取る
何もやらないでいると
ものの見事に体が壊れて年を取る
何かやるとものの見事に
もっとスピーディーに体が壊れていく
これはもうスピードスピードを上げることはできますが
下げることはできません
いくらでもあるんだから
我々には 年取って死ぬスピードは上げます
そのアクセルレートはいくらでも増えますけど
ブレーキはないんです
ギアはないんです 今 車はオートですから
でも  １ ２ ３ ４とかいろいろシフトあるでしょ
あのシフトによって車を進むスピード変わるでしょ
これが命にないんです
命には壊れていくアクセルレーターがあります
これは自由に使ってくださいと
しかし スピードを下げるブレーキはないんです
それで結論として私は言いたいのは
死を認識できないことで
ものすごく怖くなるんです
だからもう暴走してくる車も怖いし
あのオートバイでね 若者がギャーッと通って側からサッと行っちゃうと
もう怖くて怯えちゃうしね
自分がもう道路で歩いているときは
向こう側から左側から誰かがジョギングしてくる
行こうかなと思ったら
ぶつかりそうな あ 怖っとなるでしょうに
いつでもそういうことを経験するでしょ
だからそれは死を知らないから起こる恐怖感なんです
次のポイントは これ なんで恐怖があるのかという質問説明なんです
えーと あなたの人生は感情が指導する
客観性 理性 具体性 現実
真理 法則などを参考にして生きることはしていないんです
誰しも気持ちで生きているんです
子供を見てください もう気持ちばっかしで
大人も同じなんです 感情
好み 主観が人生を指導しています
要するに あなたは嘘 幻覚
現象を参考にして生きる
生きる上の判断をしているんです
生きるために必要な判断する場合は
参考にするのは何です
現象 幻覚 だから お釈迦様が別な生き方推進しているんです
人間の生き方 生命の生き方
神々の生き方はけしからんやと
あまりも無知やと 感情で判断するんだから
これ賭け事で考えてください
例えば二人で 100 万 100
万賭ける 賭けてコインを投げる
自分が 日本語で表と裏でしたっけね
ヘッドアンドテールですね
で 自分が表と言ったら
表が表になったらあなたの勝ち
あなたは表と言ったところで
裏が上になったら あなたの負けと
でお互い百万百万かけている
かけちゃうでしょ 百万もらったら楽しいでしょ？ボロ儲けでしょ
感情です でもどちら落ちるかわからないでしょ
理性で見れば 理性のある人は
あのね これ俺は儲かった
百万で頑張って苦労して仕事をして貯めたお金だから
お前みたいにバカに賭け事しませんよと
これで私はご飯食べたり
旅行したり 楽しく使います
勝手に出て行ってくださいと
それで相手がいえいえ
あんた勝ったら 100万じゃ百万200万になるでしょうにといりませんと言うんです
理性だったら でもみんなカジノに行っちゃうでしょ
金に依存するでしょ なんで麻薬
酒などに依存しているんですかね
あれ 理性 感情です 最近もどこかに記事があって読まなかったんだけど
あまりにも古臭いんだからね
最近出たアメリカなんとかの記事なんですけど
酒はものすごい体に悪いんだと
私 面白くない これ我々は 2500年前から言ってるんだよと
細胞は壊れますよと 今更あなた方の話を聞きたくないと読まなかったんです
で じゃあ酒飲む人はあれを理性で判断する？じゃあ皆様結婚してるでしょ？結婚相手を見つかって決めた時は理性で決めたの
ずっと生まれた時から死ぬまで
幻覚で現象で妄想で感情で生きているんです
感情はヘリックスであるならば
人生すべてヘリックスになっちゃうんでですよ
なってるでしょ？何やってもろくな結果がないでしょ
ですから 事実に遭遇すると怯えて震えるんです
この人はものすごい可愛いんだと
結婚したいなとかね 結婚しちゃうでしょ
女っていうのは歌舞伎役者みたいに
もうものすごく人を騙すでしょ
手を上げたり下げたりする時ね
あのコーヒーカップなんか取る時とかね
まあ見てください ドラマやってるんですね
あまりにも美しくてなまらかで
男はそれにやられちゃって
感情でね なんて美しいですかと
この飲み方とかね この喋り方
この笑い方とかね そこで結婚してみたら
あんなのは何もなくなっちゃった
女性の目的は達したんだから
もう歌舞伎役者やらなくてもいいやと
更衣室にはもう逃げるところはないんだと
捕まっちゃったんだから
それで感情だけの男だったら
かなり苦しくなるんです
長生き長持ちしないんですね
結婚は他のところで何か不倫というかね
いろいろなところに行こうとする
他の人を騙すところに行こうとするんです
だから仏教はね 結婚とかね
そういうことで判断する
この間 私にも弟の息子なんですけど
何か結婚の話が出てきて
こういう人最近不安になっているんですね
メールがあって 私はずっと長い文章で一つ文章を書いてあげたんです
感情で判断するなよと
で これは人間と人間の関係ですよと
人間と人間が仲良くなったら
お互い助け合うでしょ
相手が病気になっちゃうと助けてあげる
相手が病気になって倒れて
じゃあもうご飯で じゃあ私がご飯作って作りますからとかね
それが本当の長生きできる夫婦生活なんです
結婚する時 あんたなんか天女みたいな美人でしたけど
今はブッサイクってもう気持ち悪いと言っちゃうと
もうもうもう頭イカれてるんです
奥さんが家で掃除 掃除
洗濯 料理 子育て あれやこれやってると思うと
手なんか荒れちゃってね
もうハチャメチャになるでしょ
それが素晴らしいと思わないと
この人はすごい頑張っているんだと
我々のこの生活を維持するために
だから結婚してから この女性のあの見たくないところがありがたがらないと
体も形変わっていくし
で それは人は人を愛する
愛するって仏教用語じゃないんだけどね
まあ慈しむ 哀れむ 心配する
だから仏教は理性の教えだから
感情の結婚は認めません
あなたにはその人を慈しめますかと
心配することはできますかと
相手が正真正銘の独立した存在であると理解できますかと
できるならば それでじゃあ一緒に生活してもいいよと
お互いに助け合って はい
結婚の話ぐらいにして
誰にもそういうもう時間過ぎちゃってますからね
えーと はい これ終わったらちょっと休憩しましょう
恐怖は精神の病ですね
だから理性しっかり働かないんだから
我々には 我々に恐怖感がある
恐怖感があるということは精神病です
理性を育てない限り 恐怖感という病が悪化するだけです
これもやりますかね また
これはそんなに大事なポイントでもないんですけど
でも仏典では経典では一応扱っているところなんですね
文化の足かせっていうのは
これは私が作ったフレーズですけどね
神話 習慣 信仰 伝統 逸話
迷信などが人に妄想することを教えています
文化ってそういうものでしょ
各国に神話があるでしょう
各民族に自分なりの物語があるでしょう
すべて嘘でしょう その中で階段話もいくらでもありますね
恐怖感で脅して人を管理しようとしているのです
その文化の中で 恐怖感で人を管理する場合もあります
具体的な例を出しちゃうと
もう私のテーマが壊れちゃいますから
我々はもう例えばたたりが神のたたりがあるんだから
あちらに行くなよと 神が住んでいるんだから
この森に この山に入るなよとかね
いろんな逸話あるでしょ
日本だったら赤鬼 なんとか鬼
黄色い鬼 白い鬼はないんですね
とにかくそういういろんな
逸話ある 日本はこれではありません
この森にはなんだらかんだらの霊が住んでいる
この山にはなんだらかんだらが住んでいると
だから気をつけなさいよとか
そうやって恐怖感で祟るとか
恐怖感で人を管理しているんです
人を管理する 犯人を刺すことができないので
人は自己管理することになっているのです
じゃあ皆様は気づいていない
皆様に皆様の文化が恐怖感を与えているんです
日本の方々に日本人のしきたり
習慣が恐怖感を与えているんです
結婚式の場合のしきたり
習慣があります 披露宴の場合はしきたり習慣があります
いろいろ 妊娠したらそれなりのしきたり習慣
子供が産んだらまたいろいろ
で そこをすべてそういう文化を守りながら
裏で恐怖感がありますよ
やらなかったらやばいという恐怖
だから 犯人誰だよって文化なんですね
文化って人じゃないんですね
ですから 我々は自分で自分を管理して生活しなくちゃいけない
例えば 日本によくある
どこかの神社に行って御祈りしたら子宝に恵まれる
普通で考えれば変な神ですね
だってぐるぐる若い女に女を妊娠させちゃうんだからね
皆さんは男性の方々 そういう神になったらどうですかね
毎日もう 100人ぐらい来ますからね
で 妊娠させるだけです
で 考えてみたら まあそんなもんでしょ
だから怖くて 女が怖がらなくてもいいんで
なんだらかんだら神社に行って子宝に恵まれますようにとお祈りしなくちゃ
もうダメだとか 勝手に怖がって自己管理してください
そういう習慣がある 昔からそれだけ
そこらへん行く予定があったら
ついでに行ってもいい
私も神社は信仰してないんだけど
どこか出かけたところで有名な神社があったら
ちょっと行ってみようかなと行ってみるんですよね
ついでに だからそこで自己管理というものでするしかないんです
恐怖感を育成しながら
恐怖のない幸福に生きることを期待しますね
人間は 毎日恐怖感を育てているんです
育てながら怖くない人生が欲しいなとか
何考えてるんですかね
はい 一旦ここで休憩します
時間的に何時で いいの？これからの私の分析でまずやってきましたから
ちょっとブッダの教えに直接入ってみましょうか
釈尊は恐怖感を分析します
今も私は皆様にわかる
わかりやすいだろうと妄想して分析したんだけど
同じことなんですけど
ちょっと経典に入ってみましょうか
真面目に変えの 4番目の経典があります
このバヤベーラはすってバヤっていうのは恐怖感
ベーラっていうのは怖くて震えるという名前のタイトルの経典です
長い経典だから ほんのちょびちょびとだけ紹介します
で テーマはこういう風に始まりますね
あるバラモンが有名なバラモンですけど
あの お釈迦様よりね まああなたも一人で森で孤独
孤独で生活しているし
それ大変でしょうと あなたの弟子たちも
この怖い恐ろしい森やら墓地やらお墓やらね
そういうところに住んでいて
かなり大変でしょうね
それでみんなブッダに命をかけているんじゃないんですか？と言ったら
お釈迦様そんな通りですと
この出家している人々はかなり厳しい生活をしているんだと
すごい怖いところ 人は絶対行かないところ
もうもう痛い 捨て場やら森やら空き家やら
そういうところに住んでいて修行するんですけど
彼らが私に頼っているんだよと
私はその人々はしっかりと育てて
完全たる安穏に導いてますよと
で そういう話なんですね
それでお釈迦様は あの
今の出家はどうったことはないんだけどね
ブッダの時代の出家っていうのは
本物のお化け屋敷に住んでいるような話なんです
怖い世界なんですね 森の中でなくちゃいけないしね
そこで恐怖感は不善法であると説くので
修行者はそれを乗り越えなくてはいけないんです
お釈迦様は この恐怖感というのは不善であると
いわゆる心から取り除かなくちゃいけない現象なんです
それで なぜ人は怖くなるのか
特にこの場合は皆様のことじゃなくて
出家の修行者がものすごく怖くなってビビっちゃう
ビビるならば それはどういうことかと説明するんです
身口意の行為が汚れている場合
森林生活は難しいんですと
街から離れて 家から離れて
人が入らない森の中で
身口意の行為 汚れているんだったら
いわゆる体で悪いことをするは
言葉で悪い言葉を喋るは
頭で悪いことを考えるは
だったらもうあんた方にはもう恐怖感を乗り越えることはできないんだよと
要するに 修行者が偽善者であるならば
恐怖に遭遇すると狂うのだと語るんです
修行者は修行もどきだったら
偽善者だったら あんた頭イカれちゃうんです
恐怖感で だから仏道ってすごい
すごい世界なんです そこでじわじわといきます
お釈迦様があのバラモンの方に
自分が悟る前に心の病について研究しましたと
恐怖感とは何ぞやと研究したんです
それをずっと説明していくんです
で 一部だけ このネガティブところだけ出します
欲しいところは 思い浮かんだら言います
例えば修行者 これ仏教に限ってない
どんな宗教でも修行者がアビッジャールーカーメスティッバラガ
異常欲ですごい欲がある
五欲に対して強烈な愛着があること
いるんですよ だからインドでも有名なサードたちが修行してきて
ボロ儲け すごい金持ちになっちゃって
もう何人も女のお世話役
若い子囲まって楽々ゴージャス王様みたいな生活する人々もいるんですね
だからあれ 修行ってことじゃないでしょう
だからそんな目的で金儲けてゴージャスで生活する目的で出家して修行しちゃうと
あなた方には修行できんやと
恐怖感で頭がイカれるんだよと
だからシロクマが住んでいるところであろうか
グリズリーが住んでいる
最近行ってきたんだからね
グリズリーが住んでいるところであろうか
欲がなければ あれを楽しみたい
これを楽しみたいというものなくなったら
もう隣にグリズリーがいたっても別に問題なく木の下で座っていられます
グリズリー知ってます
あの北部の方にいるね
ブラウンベアと かなり怖いクマですね
2番目 アクサラーナんば
あ  2番目ではない アクサラーナんばえべーばエベレスト
アウハアウハーヤンティ
だから欲がある人 修行者が不戦の恐怖感に襲われるんだと
だからこれは皆様にあたり関係ない
だから皆様にしたっても
あまり欲深いんだったら
ものすごく恐怖感にやられるんです
欲深いんだったら 異常欲だったら
2番目 ビャーパンのチッタパドゥッテマナサンカッパということは
異常の怒りがあって 常に不機嫌な気持ちでいる
そこで怒りのせいで出家する人もいる
この社会は嫌だ この連中と生活したくないんだとか
仕事をしたくないんだとかね
怒りですね で 私にも連絡来るんです
出家したいんだよと だから本人気づいてない
出家したいと要求する要求する人々はいるんだけど
みんな私には何の資格もないんだから出家させてくださいと言ってる話です
だから迷惑でしょうに
資格がなければ  2番目はこの怒り
瞋恚 いつでも不機嫌で
何でも非難する 何でも誹謗中傷する
何でも悪口を言う その人は修行していても恐怖感で頭イカレちゃってしまいます
とにかく言いますけど
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する場合は悟れますよ
しかし これがヴィパッサナーで真理ありのままに丸裸で経験するんです
これかなり怖いんです
しかし 心で怒り 嫉妬 憎しみがない
欲がない心だったら 何の
ああ そういうことかと
と思って智慧が現れるんです
3番目 ティーナミッドパリウッディタ
これ日本語訳書いてないみたい
ティーナミッドっていうのは
この昏睡睡眠 いつだって昏睡睡眠で何か居眠りしながらいつでも
そういう性格の人は 森に入っちゃうともうイカれちゃいますよ
4番目 ウッダタアウォウパサンタチッタ
で ウッダタっていうのは何か興奮状態で
もう何かこの野生の動物を突然こちらに入れたような感じで
もう暴れちゃって そういう状態
アウォウパサンタチッタ
心は落ち着いてない だったら恐怖感に負けますと
5番目 カンキービチキッチ
関係っていうのは 疑が疑があること
心は疑問だらけ どうでしょうかね
あれ 本当にそう？本当にそう？そういう通りなる？とかね
信じられないとかね そういう心は弱いんですね
それだったらもうどうしようもない
6番目 アットカンサカパラワンビー
自分をいつでも褒めたくて褒めたくて
自分が偉い 自分が偉い
自分が正義だ ばっかりで
人のことは貶す あの人々はなんのこともないと
そういう性格だったら恐怖感にやられるんです
7番目 チャンビービールカジャーティカ
これ性格的にチャンビーっていうのはすごい臆病で
揺らぐ精神で性格的に怖がり屋なんですね
チャンビーっていうのはいつでも怖い怖い怖いという
そういう人々いるんですね
だから初めからの精神病気の状態がひどいんですね
だから出家ふさわしくないんです
あ 怖っと思っちゃう人には出家できません
ビールカジャーティカ
ほんのちょっとこと ほんのちょっとのことでも怖がっちゃう
8番目はラーバサッカラーシローカンニカーマエマーナ
時々出家するんですよ
この他人からね いろいろお布施いただいて
他人から褒めてもらってね
褒め称えること 尊敬されることを期待する
それでという出家ふさわしくない
時々日本の方々はこの現象を見ますけど
いい人々ですけど ずっと出家してあげちゃうと
テーラワーダ世界ではもう出家した人はすごい尊敬するんですね
そこで日本の方だと頭がちょっとおかしくなっちゃうんです
だって普通日本だったら誰も手を合わせてくれないでしょう
無理も丁寧に手を合わせてお世話しちゃうと
自分が処理できなくなっちゃって
なんか自分が偉いでしょうと思っちゃう
勘違いするんです そういう人々にも修行はできないし
修行したっても頭が怖さでイカれちゃうんです
9番目 クシータヒーネリーリヤ
これは怠けで精進しない
怠け者にはもう恐怖感なくすことはできません
10番目 ムッタッサティアサンパジャーナ
ムッタッサティ 気づきがない
だからどんな問題にも仏教はたった一つの解決法を教えているんです
気づきなさいと 気づきを実践しなさい
私はヴィパッサナー瞑想
ヴィパッサナー瞑想と言っているのは
気づきの実践なんです
これができないんだったら
もうお手上げ それからアサンパジャーナ
承知 物事をその場でその場で理解する能力がないと
で無理なんです 私はいつでも辛口言っているように皆様は勘違いしていると思います
辛口じゃない のもの 一言葉でチャラっと言っちゃうでしょうに
これって承知能力なんですね
見たら 例えば子宝に恵まれてくれる神社があったら
その神様何やってるんですかと
で ちょっとの考えなんですね
11番目 アサマヒタヴィッバンタチッタ
アサマヒタっていうのは心の統一がない
心があちらこちら あちらこちら走り回ってあちら向いてイライラ状態で
一つに集中して落ち着いていることはできない
だったら その人も恐怖感に負ける
だからお釈迦様がそういうのを弟子たちに教えるんですよ
あんた方はね 人々に尊敬してもらうために
人々からお布施をもらうために出家しているんじゃないんだよと
これよく捨てなさいよ
それからしっかりと 24時間気づきを実践しなさいよと
目の前で何が起きているのかよく知っておきなさいよと
それから常に統一性を保ちなさいよと
心の  12ドゥッパンニャーエーラモガー
これはもうどうしようもない条件で完全無知
いわゆる認知障害状態
あの そういう障害を持って生まれる人間もいますね
認識能力はない その場合はもう恐怖感で生活するしかないんです
うちら 16あると経典にどこかに括弧の中で入れてあったんだけど
編集者がね 私は数えて数えても一つ足らなかったんですね
3つ瞋恚の行為で省略してしまったから
それも 15なんです 人々は一番怖がる日々
お釈迦様の研究なんですね
インド文化では 新月 満月
半月は鬼たちが降りてくる
お化けが出る一番悪い日なんです
で 曜日でいえば土曜日と水曜日
まあ超怖い曜日なんです
だから文化っていうのは人に恐怖感を与えるんですよ
インド文化の人々は自分の国でも同じなんですけど
まあ土曜日は必ず体を清めて
土曜日 サタデーですね
清めて神社とかああいうところに行くんです
行ってお祈りしてお供えして帰るんです
次 水曜日  文化の足かせになってない人にとってはどうったことはない
そういうことで この人々が
文化が この日が怖い この日が怖い
この日はお化けが出る
この日は悪魔が出る この日という日は鬼が出る
あの場所にはもう満月
新月は鬼が出るとかね
そういう場所がありますよ
恐怖の聖地 恐怖の聖地と言えないね
恐怖スポット お釈迦様はブッダ
ブッダになる前に いわゆる菩薩の時
そういうところに行くんです
そうすると弟子もいなかったでしょ
たった一人 まだ悟ってないんだから
人を首をひねって血を吸って殺す鬼が出る場所があると聞いたら
その鬼がいつ出るのかといったら
あの半月 いわゆる日が月が欠けている時の半月と聞いたら
その日で行くんです また夜
また一人で だからスーッと朝まで一人で
スーッとそちらで待って観察するんです
それでお釈迦様はまだブッダではないし
我々と同じく悟ってないし
だから突然すごい音が来るんだと
ダラダラーンと え？でビビるでしょ
お釈迦様も それは観察する
なんだ その音は といったら
まあ枯れた枝が落ちたと
あるいは自分がもう瞑想
座って瞑想してるんだから
目を閉じて 暗闇の中でものすごいもう樹海の中でいるんですよ
そこで誰か自分の前でサーッと走っていっちゃう
鬼でしょ お釈迦様は目を
あ ただ鹿が走ったと そういうふうに観察するんです
こんなことで このアホたちが恐怖感に襲われているんだよと
それで結論に達するんです
その時ももう一つやったんです
例えば 立って歩いたりして瞑想するときは
何か突然音が来たり 何か突然ドカンと落ちたり
だって森っていうのは超うるさいところなんですよ
樹海っていうのは静かじゃないんです
日本とはちょっと違うと思います
日本ってそんなに野生動物はいないんだから
だから空き家とかね 森とか静かな場所だと
こういう経典にある 私
個人的な感想がうるさくてしょうがないという
夜にしたっても いろんな野生
夜行動物いるでしょ 猿のグループに入る
この木を登るちっちゃな動物たち
それいろいろ食べ物を取ったり
高い木に登って食べてポスンと落ちたんですね
だから食べたものを果物でも
あるいは殺した動物の死骸とかね
座って瞑想をしている自分の膝の上にドカンと落ちたらどうなる？何も見えないし
真っ暗でしょうに 何の光もないでしょうに
怖くなるでしょ で お釈迦様は怖くならなびびっちゃうんですね
で なんだこれはと座っている時
ちょっとビビったら そのビビったことをその場で座ったままでなくす
立っている時はちょっとあっとなったら
そのままで その瞬間でそれをなくすと
こういうことでこうなったのかと
あの時々 暗闇で歩くとか
この落ちた枝とかいろいろあるでしょ
この枝に枝がちょっと足に引っ張っちゃう
引っかかる どうなる？皆さんに経験ないね
森でヘビがいる 毒蛇が
もし折れた枝が足にクッとなったところで
ちょっとかすり傷をつく
あれ ヘビだったらどうする？怖くなるでしょうに
あ 噛まれたと だって暗闇だからヘビを踏んだ可能性もあるでしょうに
お釈迦様だったら もう立ったと
歩いた時 何か引っかかっちゃい
それを観察する 見たらヘビではなく枝が当たっただけで
はい ちょっと落ち着いて
はい 次に行くという実践してみたんですね
もし心が少々でもビビったら
ただその場でそれをなくす訓練をしたのです
逃げること 安全なところを探すことはない
私たちはビビったらどうする？逃げる
ちっちゃい子供をちょっと怖がらせて
怖がらせてください 怖がる途端
お母ちゃーんって言って逃げるでしょ
安全な場所に逃げるんです
あれで恐怖感には勝てっこはないんです
みんなそういうことをするんです
で 仏教の修行者はそちらにいるんです
死んだ人が怖いと 痛いは怖いと思ったら
痛い捨て場に行け 夜一人でインドで遺体捨てるという習慣もあったんだからね
貧しい人々の遺体は火葬しない
捨てる 遺体捨て場はどうしても人々がいる場所じゃない
村から何キロも離れたところ
険しいところ 野生動物はものすごくいるところ
特にキツネ 狼 犬 それテレビで見ると可愛いんだけどね
野生のあの連中はすごく怖いんですよ
攻撃するんです 噛まれたらもう
だからこういうキツネたちやら野生の犬たちやら狼たちやらが来て
遺体パクパクと食べてるんでしょ
そちらに夜行って じーっと座って待ってるんです
そこで研究するんです
いかにこの恐怖感が現れるのかと
そこで発見したのはここ
この 12 の項目 これ本当は真空入れちゃうと 15 になるんです
あっ 心が汚れてると 欲があると怒りがあると
これダメやと だからそれがなければ何のこともないんだよと
で 発見するんです はい
それで今までの話をまとめてみます
心に貪瞋痴がある 偽善的
この偽善というのはみんなにありますよ
我々はだいたい本来自分にあるものより見せるんですね
心に それから自我出張
判断に乏しい 人生に期待しすぎ
怠け 勇気がない 臆病 認識能力に欠陥があるなどが怯えて震える理由になります
はい 最後 本当に怖いものは何なのかと
妄想 主観から現れるいい加減な恐怖ではなく
現実的に恐るべき ものがあるんです
恐るべきものがあるんですよ
幽霊が怖い お化けが怖い
いい加減なそんなのはね
他民族が怖いとか 黒人が怖いとか
スリランカ人が怖いと言ったら
それは認めますけどね
私のことを知ってるんだから
皆様は で こんないい加減なことじゃなくて
本当に怖いと感じるべきものはあるんです
はい 恵みの女神の問い
キンスジャネーティ プリサンキンスタッサヴィダーヴァティ
キンスサンサーラマーパーディキンスタッサマハッバヤンという質問がある女神がブッダに出しちゃったんです
私はちょっといい加減日本語訳したんです
人という生命ですね 人を産むのは誰ですか？と
この生命は誰が産むんですかと
で 産むという単語はあまり日本的じゃないんだけど
直訳するとそうなっちゃうんです
生命を走らせ 走らせる
いわゆる生かされるのは誰ですか？と
輪廻をする生命に最大の恐怖とは何ですか？と質問するんです
こんなややこしい質問するんだからね
あまり神々に仲良くしない方がいいんです
もうあの連中何聞くかわからないんだから
お釈迦様だからよかったんです
こんなことを私に聞いたら
私は出て行けと言うんです
はい ブッダの答え タンナージャネーティ
プリサンチッタマッサヴィダーヴァティ
サットーサンサーラマーパーディ
ドゥッカマッサマハッバヤン
私のいい加減な日本訳
渇愛が人生命を生むのです
神じゃないんです 渇愛
タンハ ジャネーティ プリサ
心が生命を走らせている
走らせ 生かされているんです
だから この物体の中に心がかすどせているんです
だからこの物体は生きているんです
ご飯を食べたいと思うのは心なんです
で 体の肉体の物質がちょっと減ったなと心が感じるんです
だったらご飯を食べると
水分が減ったなと思ったら
減ったことは心が感じるんです
機械は感じません ただ
車にガソリン燃料がないんだとわかるのは車ですかね
車じゃないんです 人間がわかるんです
そのようにこの体を車にしてみれば
何か心があって あ お腹が空いた
喉が渇いた 足が痛くなった
眠くなったとかね そういう心があって生きているんです
いわゆる心は命を生かしているんです
輪廻にはまっている生命には
苦が最大の恐怖です これがブッダの決定的な言葉で
難しいとは思います 最大の恐怖は苦ということなんです
あれは お釈迦様は 4つの真理を語ったでしょう
聖なる真理  1番目は苦
正体なんですね いわゆる生きることが苦であると
これは大胆な言葉なんです
すべての生命は生きることが素晴らしいであると思っているんです
研究していない 勝手に決まっているんです
生きることが客観的で科学的に見るならば
苦であると逆さまです
一般人の考えとブッダの考えは
発見は 生きる場合は 生老病死などの四苦八苦が確実にあるんです
四苦八苦という言葉は日本語でもよく使える言葉なんですね
生老病死は 4つですね
愛別離苦 怨憎会苦 それから何でしたっけ？まあ
うん 欲しいものが得られない
欲しいものは得られないもの
得られないこと それから
アピールアンビバレント
ジャンピッチェンラビタンビドゥカン
期待するものは得られないという
欲しいものは得られないことというふうな苦がいろいろあるんです
これが人生でしょ 年取らないと生きてないでしょ
最初の単細胞で生まれるでしょ
細胞は年取っていくんです
それは成長するんだ 生きてるんだ
同時に老化もしているんです
そこで病気 というのは
細胞に 根本的にあるんです
本質として細胞一個も病気ない
だからそれぐにゃぐにゃにして分解したり
いろいろなことをやっているんです
だから病気 病がなければ生きられません
しかし 病気そのものが嫌なもんなんですよ
で それがなかったら生きられません
だから命とは生老病死なんです
それが好むものじゃないでしょ
24時間頑張らなくちゃいけない
終わりがない お布団に入ったからといって
あれ 休み？休みじゃない
生き続けているんです
夢を見るんです 寝返りはしているんです
いびきをかいているんです
いろんなことをやっているんです
そこで 寝るときでも体の体調が悪くなったり
いろんな苦しみですよ
目が覚めた瞬間で 新たな苦しみが生まれる
これはやるわやる どこまでやるのかと
終わりがなく やってやって
やり やり続けているんです
何も何回やればいいかと自分に聞いてみてください
何回お風呂に入ればいいんですかね？何回歯を磨ければいいんですかね
じゃあ 歯がある限りと言ったってもね
歯がなくなったら我は入れ歯を入れるでしょ
それで入れ歯のお世話しなくちゃいけないんだから
終われないんです これらを最大の恐怖として見なすべきです
だからお化けが怖いではなくて
生きることが怖いんです
生きることが苦なんです
だったら生きることに愛着捨てるんです
苦から苦 苦から苦 苦から苦の連続だから
アホ以外は愛着しないんです
だから観察するとこれわかるんです
私は手を上げたり下げたり
立ったり座ったり 回ったり
苦しみがやらせているんです
幽霊が怖いなど幼稚的な感情ではないんですね
仏教が考えている恐怖っていうのは生きることです
変な答えですね だからあれ怖い
これ怖いではなくて お前が怖いんだと
私自身が怖いということを感じなくちゃあかんです
幽霊が怖いではなくて
幽霊がいても平気でいいでしょうに
だから自分に愛着あるから怖いでしょうに
幽霊がね 恨めしやとこういう感じで現れてきたっても
あんたに他の曲ないの？と聞けば
これは聞き分けちゃってるんだよと
だからそれは人間が作っている物語で
私は一度も経験したことはないんです
幽霊が恨めしやと言ってくるのね
で だから本当のことは
私自身が恐怖の塊であって
生きることが怖いものであって
だから生きることに対する愛着を捨てるべきということなんですね
はい あとでどれぐらい時間残っている？ 20 分ぐらいです
うーん じゃあ続けなくなっちゃったんですね
で 私たちは生きることに愛着を持っている
生きていきたいと思っている
理由はない 研究していない
生きてなんて楽しいと思ってしまうんです
本当に生きることが楽しいかと
怖いから なんで仕事に行く？仕事に行かなかったら怖いでしょ
なんで金を儲かっている？お金がなかったらやばいでしょ
なんでスーパーで買い物の場合は
賞味期限なんだらかんだら見る？怖いからでしょ
で ラベルにね こちらでは乳製品
卵のなんだらかんだらアレルゲン
アレルゲンはこれこれ入ってますよと
これで何か食べ物のあれ読んだら
このアレルギーがあるものではなかったんで
でもこの工場では乳製品
なんだらかんだらも作ってますよと警告はあるんです
だからアレルギーある人が買っても
これあんた気をつけてくださいなんです
それ幸福感 恐怖感でしょ
例えば卵アレルギーの人がいる
どこまで気をつければいいんですかね
ケーキは食べられない
食パンにしたっても 調べて調べて調べまくらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
で 小麦粉アレルギーだったらどうする？だからなんで服を着るの？怖いからなんです
なんで靴を履いてるの？怖いからなんです
なんで家を作るの？怖いからなんです
でも 生きるためには家を作らなくちゃいけない
勉強しなくちゃいけない
仕事を見つけなくちゃいけない
結婚しなくちゃいけない
やらなかったら怖い ということは
生きることが怖いんです
じゃあそこで解決策ある？勉強したからといって
学校 大学 優秀で合格したからといって何かある？何か保証でもないでしょ？じゃあ大会社に就職できた
安全 安全 ああ 大丈夫 言える？ないでしょ
時々 この我々に想像できないマンモス会社のお金の関係でドカーンと倒れるでしょ
こちら日本は安全やと思っていたっても
金融関係でアメリカで何かちょっとした波が押しちゃうと
どうですか？日本の状況はそういう時は
だから みんな頑張ってます
なぜ？怖いからなんです
なんで奥さんの機嫌取ろうしている？怖いからなんです
なんで一生懸命子供の機嫌を取って楽しくさせてあげようと思っている
そうしなかったら どんな結果になるかわからないんです
子供を無視しちゃったらすごい怖いんです
だから 出かける前にちゃんと電気を消して
ガスコンロを全部消して調べて
窓をチェックして なんで？怖いからでしょ
道路を渡る時は左を見て
右を見て 上を見て 下を見て渡らなくちゃいけないんです
渡って横をあれこれ見ている間に信号も変わってる
変わってるんですね なんでそんなことをやっているのか
怖いからなんです 最低日本ではどこでも
電車にチケット買う場合でも
みんな丁寧に並んでるでしょ？なんで？怖いからなんです
郵便局に行ったっても
銀行にいたっても 番号を引いてじっと待っている
自分の番号を呼ばれるまで
なんでそんなに行儀よく振る舞う？怖いからでしょ？だから恐怖感でしょ
全部すべて生きることそのものが
だったら愛着捨てましょう
生きることにはろくなことがないんです
何も愛着ない心が自由自在
解放なんです 何が変化したっても
何のこともないんです
地震が起きたら別に自然現象でしょうと
あなたの家も地震で まあ別に自然
自然現象だからね 家が潰れた
それで終わり 自分が愛する人々は病気で死んじゃったら
まあ病気で誰だって死ぬから死んじゃったよと
あ 死んでほしくないと思ったならば
恐怖感が生まれてくる
これは自然の流れだと思って生きてる人にとっては安穏でいられるんです
そういうことで 最大の恐怖感は
最大の怖さは生きることです
空です 生きるとは空ですね
それはブッダの最終的な結論です
じゃあいい加減やめましょうね
じゃあどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
歩く瞑想をしている最中に不安が出てきたので
不安 不安と実況中継したんですけども
なかなか不安が消えてくれなかったので
そのまま不安を無視して歩く瞑想を続けました
足裏の感覚に意識を向けながら
ずっと歩く瞑想してたんですけども
根底にまだ不安が残っている感じで
瞑想中ずっとその不安を抑圧したような感じで歩く瞑想を続けてしまったんですけども
やり方としてはこれで正しいでしょうか？あと
思考とか妄想が出る時も
こう 妄想 妄想と実況中継して妄想を叩き潰すようにしてるんですけども
ちょっと妄想がちょっと漏れるというか
根底に妄想が抑えてるんだけど残ってる感じで
結局瞑想中完全に消えはしないというか
そんな状態なんですけども
このまま続けてもいいんでしょうか
続けるしかはないんですけど
あの もうちょっとあの腕上げてほしいんですね
まだまだもうちょっと初期的なレベルでヴィパッサナーやってるんですから
例えば歩く瞑想やってると不安
不安だったっけ  不安ですね
不安が出たと この不安って何なのかと
そこで観察することができたならばね
歩いてるままで 何が不安でしょうかね
右足上げること？右足を下ろすこと？客観的に見ると変でしょ？不安になったことは
仕事のことで不安を抱えていて
その仕事のことがちょっと頭から
でしょ？だからあなたは歩く瞑想をちょっとおろそかにして飛んだんですね
あの妄想の世界に 妄想の世界に不安があります
妄想世界が不安の塊です
だからそちらにちょっと飛んじゃったんですよ
それだけ だから今ここは何やと
今なんで不安なのかと
と厳しく観察するんです
右足上げること 何が不安ですかね
運ぶ 何が不安ですかね
下ろすと そう見ると アホじゃないかと
自分がと 余計なことをね
修行修行をちょっとおろそかにしてサボって馬鹿を見ているんだと
それだけそう発見すると
すごいなんとなく前よりはもうしっかりするんです
それでまた不安が襲ってきたら
もう能力あるんで処理する能力
その不安は無視してもいいでしょうかね
無視することじゃないですよ
言ったのは  観察  観察する
観察をずっと続け 不安がどこから来るのかを観察して
だから現実的に観察してください
現実的に今あなたに不安があるのかと
これは妄想から出た結果でしょ
妄想すればお化けが怖いと妄想したら怖いでしょうね
だからこれをずっと説明したんだからね
だから妄想 幻覚から恐怖感
不安が出てくるんです
それは最初からもう処理する
それから 存在欲の不安は瞑想実践で解決しなくちゃいけないんです
だから怖くなったら あれ
なんで怖いの？と自分で聞いてみてください
修行中  それは歩く瞑想
一回立ち止まって 不安
どこから不安が来ているのかを観察して
原因がわかったらまた歩く
そうそうそう その通り
やってみてください 気持ちが変わったらカチッと足を止めて
なんだこれ？と観察する
腕を上げてください 腕を上げると結構きつくなります
だから子供が絵を描くような感じで
まだまだ下手だからうまく行かないんですね
子供しっかり線を描きたいんだけど
手がまだ柔らかい 弱いんだからね
ごちゃごちゃになっちゃうんですね
そういう感じですね もうちょっと腕上げれば大丈夫だと思います
はい  すいません もう一つでしょうか
えっと 自分というものが無常で
瞬間瞬間生まれては消滅するならば
性格というものも変わっていくんでしょうか？それとも性格というのは業から発しているものなので
ずっと変わらないものなんでしょうか
うん あの これはもう流れとして見たらわかると思いますね
だから川といったら瞬間瞬間変化するんだけど
よくよく観察して 例えば 1時間観察すると
1 日観察すると あるパターンで流れるということが見えてくる
正確にそういうものなんですね
だからそれも確定するものじゃないんですね
例えば 1時間の荒川を観察する
その時はこんな感じだなとわかってきますよ
でも次の日行ってみたら
また荒川の流れが別の流れになっています
そのように物事は変化して流れるんだから
それぞれのパターンが現れてくるんです
我々性格っていうのはそういうものなんです
例えば この花に心でいい感覚が生まれたら
あなたはこの花が好きと言っちゃうんです
私の性格だよと 言ってることだけなんですね
じゃあではなくて この花はそれは別にってことになるんですね
それを性格と言うでしょ
大したことないパターンですね
例えば皆様日本人の方々だから
外国に行ったっても ホテルで日本食があるとずるずるとそちらに行くでしょ
だって他のものは食べられない
食べられますよ でも行っちゃうんですね
日本人だからパターンが出来上がってるんですね
なんとか安心 日本和食あったら
例えば大きいホテルでアフリカン料理もあると
えっと エジプトの料理もあるんだと
面白い 面白いねとか思っちゃいますよ
エジプト料理 うーん エジプト料理方法で作ったチキンがあって
うーん やっぱり日本の唐揚げにしました
なりますよ それは食べる時の現れたパターンなの
正確にそういうものなんですね
だからそれはそんなに気にすることじゃないんです
そんなに気にすることじゃない
例えば自分の なんて言いますか
ハンドライティング 手で書く場合は自分のパターンがあるでしょ
例えば 誰でも あ これはあの人が書いたもの
これはこの人が書いたものと言えるでしょ
だからといって これをわざわざ変える必要ある？ないんです
だからサインする場合は性格合った方がいいんです
十回サインする十種類だったら大変ですよ
だから性格というものは害がない場合はもう気にするものじゃないんです
例えばいつでも怒りっぽい
これは迷惑ですね そういうのは
まあ直す方に直せるように頑張るんです
そういうのは えっと 瞑想を続けていれば
まあ瞑想続ければ 直す必要ない性格はそのままであって
どうしても直さなくちゃいけない性格はプログラムで直ります
問題ないんです うん  ありがとうございました
ではもうひと方 では後ろの方
マイク  ありがとうございます
えーと あの 今日の本とか読んで
過去っていうのはもう死んじゃったもので
何も意味がないっていうか
そういうことを読んだことがあるんですけど
よく僕は日常的に自分の過去の何か嫌だったことだとか
何か失敗したこととか
何かそういうのが心の中に浮かんできて
それに結構囚われてしまう自分っていうのがいて
何かすごいその時 すごい自分も嫌な気持ちになったりとか
何かやっぱ囚われてるのはわかるんですね
そういったものが本当になくなれば
もっとなんかこう楽に生きて
人生をもっと楽に生きられるんじゃないかなっていうふうな思いがあって
やっぱりそういうのっていうのは
こう瞑想をすることでしかなくならないんですかね
いや 瞑想するまで待たないでください
早く直してください そんな難しくないんです
過去は失敗しました だからあんた今も失敗する
だからそこはもう勇気にもと
過去は失敗しちゃったんだから
今度は失敗するもんじゃないよと思っちゃえば終わりでしょ
話は  それがまた心の中で繰り返してくるっていうか
やっぱ  だから癖になってるんだから
何回も繰り返してくるかも
いくら繰り返してもまた開き直ればいいんです
そうするともう大体一日二日
三日でそれは治りますよ
だから瞑想しなくちゃって言ったら
それは気が弱いってことのいいわけ
それには言い訳を使う必要ないんです
そうだよ 私は過去でものすごい失敗しましたからね
と開き直るんです だから今回は失敗しません
だって今回成功する 成功させなくちゃあかんや
なんで 過去失敗したから
そういう風にアプローチを変えてください
すぐ治ります だから症状によりますから
何回薬を飲めばいいかっていうことは出てきますよ
だからこの過去に引っ張られる
引っかかるということは病気なんですね
この病気のレベルに合わせて治療の回数は決めるんです
軽いんだったら一回の治療で OK
それほど軽くはないんだったら
まあ何回何回も繰り返さなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし 一生治療の薬飲むことだけはやめてください
だから自分が過去に引っ張られる
この回数 フリークエンシー
それをチェックして だから今回は失敗しないと決めればいいんです
だから今回失敗しないために過去の失敗を使うんです
それは普通 日本語で過去の経験を生かすと言ってるでしょ
過去の経験を生かすとは？過去の経験すべて正しいからじゃないんです
過去の経験はちゃめちゃですよ
よく考えると成功した覚えがないぐらいです
私の場合でも ハチャメチャなんです
でもそうだから今生かすんです
ですから そんなに難しくないんです
頑張ってください  ありがとうございます
では あとひとかた  セッションのセッションのことについてお聞きしたいんですけれども
最近 自分の部屋に羽のついた小さいアリが夜たくさん電灯の光に誘われて入ってきたんです
窓を閉めて それがあの 2
回ぐらいあったので 大家さんに電話連絡したらですね
大家さんが勝手にアリの業者
アリを駆除する業者 殺す業者に連絡して
日取りを決めてあの対策を打ちますということで連絡が来たんです
私はアリの業者に駆除してくださいというふうに依頼は直接してなかったんですけども
大家さんが勝手にそういう判断をして私に連絡が来たので
私は後で考えて それはあの私が大家さんにその話をしたところ
結果結果的にアリの巣が駆除されるのではないかという推測が予想されて推測できたので
それは間接的な殺生なんじゃないかと思って
大家さんにそれをキャンセルしてもらったんですね
で その時 大家さんとあまり話す時間がなかったので
大家さんが後日 私はその理由
殺生という理由を話さなかったので
大家さんが後で私にまた連絡をしてきたんですね
私はそれで殺生ということが気になりますということをお話しした
あの それはそれでご判断にお任せしますということだったんですけども
大家さんはあの 貸してる家がですね
自分財産になるので その家がアリにですね
あの壊される可能性があるということを私に言ってきたので
私はそれで迷って では私が直接殺生をするわけではないので
家屋がですね 家がアリに殺される
壊されることは大家さんの財産が失われることになるので
それは私の管轄外ですので
大家さんのご判断にお任せしたいですというふうにお話をしまして
で 大家さんは私の気持ちも汲んでくださったので
あの 私に判断を任せるということだったんですけども
ちょっと私は間接的な殺生ということがどこまで通用するのかわからなかったので
大家さんの財産のことも心配したので
大家さんにお任せしますということで
大家さんがアリの駆除を
いやいや まあまあいいです
いいです まああんたは
[笑い] あなたにとってはそれ以外は何もできないでしょ
ですから まあいいんじゃないですかね
で 我々はいくら頑張っても生命は死ぬことは避けられませんしね
だからまあ 各生命は自分の運命によって殺されたり死んだりいろいろするしね
それはもう手には負えないんですね
だから意図的に殺意を持って自分個人の責任で殺生するだけは
まあ徹底的にやめる しかし
自然の流れで送る生命が死ぬことがどうにもならない
だからあなたは殺してくれと言ったならば
あなたの責任にもなる
気持ち悪いとかね アリがいてとかね
で 私はこういう気持ちだよと言ったら
大家さん 大家さんがそれを理解したならば
あなたはセーフですね
それから自分の財産を守ることによって
自分が地獄に落ちるのはその人の仕事なんです
それは私たちにはどうすることもできない
ですから あんたのアプローチは私はそれで正しいと思います
ありがとうございます
間接的な殺生っていうのはちょっと難しいテーマだと思うんですけども
仏教でいう縁起というものを考えた際に
まあ仏教では自分の意
が業になるんだから 間接なんたらなんたらではないんだ
間接っていうのは自分が指令すると自分の意思なんです
間接っていうのは自分の手でやらなかっただけの話ですよ
そんな難しい話じゃないんです
例えばスーパーでチキン買う場合は間接的にこうしたことになるんだよ
余計なね それは 余計に妄想すると
我々は買うから鶏を殺しているのではないかの
ないんではないかとかね
思うのはいい 勝手でいいんだけど
スーパーに入ったチキンは誰も買わないことで処分されたということもないんですね
また冷凍庫に入れちゃいますから
誰か買うまで だからそこまでは個人に管理できないんだから
余計なことそれは 私たちは自分で管理できる範囲で生活すればいいんだ
正しく 間接間接というのはそんな程度なんですよ
だから人にお金あげて
あいつを殴ってくださいと言ったら
自分が殴ったことになるんです
いや 私が殴ってない でもあんたお金払ったでしょうにと
そこは間接的に自分の罪になる
スーパーでチキン買ったからといって
あの鶏さん殺したことには自分は関係ないんです
その場合は なぜならば
それはもう管理不可能な世界に入っているんです
はい そんな大きな問題ではありません
はい  それでは時間が過ぎておりますので
これで終了といたします
では  作りにしたいので
はい もう一回 今日の説法の布施なさった柳淳医師さんにもう一度感謝いたします
幸福でありますように
えーと はい 最後の祈願を読み上げて終了しましょう
はい ご一緒に唱えてください
ドゥッカパッターチェニン ドゥッカ
バヤンパッターチェニン バヤ
スーカッパッターチェニ スーカ
ホントゥ サンベー ピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
カンティー パラマン タポーティ ティンカー ニッバーナ パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ